et si certains masquant tissus faits
maison n'était en fait pas assez
efficaces contre le virus
avec l'arrivée des variantes le haut
conseil de santé publique recommande de
ne plus utiliser certains masques
dès l'âge de 6 ans le conseil et nous
recommande d'utiliser de façon
préférentielle des masques grand public
de catégorie 1
les personnes qui se sont fabriqué leurs
propres masques y compris en suivant les
normes afnor sur internet devrait
basculer vers des masques plutôt
industriels dont les normes de
filtration correspondent au moins à 90 %
douce france cher pays de mon enfance
ils ont hâte appalaches inc est cw
remonte à la presse
[Rires]
bienvenue dans l' isolement à la
chinoise ça se passe en ce moment dans
le nord du pays 3000 maisons en
construction en un temps record les
travaux ont commencé mercredi dernier ça
fait moins d'une semaine et vous allez
voir ça va très vite les ouvriers
travaillent jour et nuit pour construire
ces maisons qui vont accueillir des
quatre contacts parce que le pays a
placé en quarantaine
vingt mille personnes originaires de
cette province
sa faute de quoi les territoires du
nord-ouest cercle arctique suis là dans
mon jacuzzi au thé vert ans qu'il s'est
tout confort enfin presque à chaque
espace fait dix-huit mètres carrés là
vous avez un aperçu des sanitaires et à
la télévision
wi fi la 5g également en volume pourquoi
et lac leamy
alors pourquoi un tel empressement parce
que la chine connaît en ce moment une
résurgence des camps et que ces cas
viennent principalement de cette
province sont 44 nouveaux cas alors nous
ça nous paraît pas beaucoup vu d'ici
mais là bas les autorités affirment
qu'ils en ont pas vu autant depuis le
mois de mars
personne ne veut revivre l'année
dernière à part en jeu vidéo dans 2020
le jeu il faut survivre aux événements
que l'on vient de connaître incendie
inondation et course à la présidentielle
américaine
et bien sûr la crise du coc vide avec
les virus à éviter la ruée dans les
supermarchés et les théories
complotistes sur la 5g
ce mini jeux amateurs gratuit et jouable
sur navigateur internet est plébiscité
sur les réseaux sociaux
les quatre dernières années ont été
inoubliables alors que donald et moi
conclure notre passage à la maison
blanche
je pense à toutes les personnes que j
ramener chez moi dans mon coeur est à
leur incroyable histoire d'amour de
patriotisme et de détermination et utile
soyez passionné dans tout ce que vous
faites mais rappelez vous toujours que
la violence n'est jamais la réponse et
ne sera jamais justifié je dirais qu
russification crucifix qu'à sion c'est
ce que vous avez dit regardez qu'est ce
que c'est que ce bruit
non non non non
ah bon je ne peux pas vous dire pourquoi
es tu fais ça basée comme ça à dire vu
comme ça on connaissait les hashtag mitu
mais il y aura désormais aussi le
hashtag mais tous plouf
suite à cette terrible agression à
l'aqualand de limoges
[Applaudissements]
faites l'amour pas ce que c'est a jugé
tout un chapitre sur le sexe pour dire
que tu as quel point mais c'est assez
exigeant pour quatre importants vous
savez que 21 une évacuation par mois oui
mecs ça réduit de 40 % le risque de
cancer de prostate ses intérêts sa
circulation il s'agit pas de solitaire
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dans votre bouche le grâce à ça
fait comment t'as fait une sorte
d'engagement ça fait bien bien et parce
que le gras en fait c'est ce qu'ils
transportent les saveurs s'il n'y a pas
de grade les saveurs ne persiste pas
dans la bouche et c'est ça qui excite le
bourgeon du goût et qui envoie au
cerveau le fait que ces bons agréable
que ça a du goût donc c'est pour ça que
d'un organe des patrouilles des dépôts
terry enfin je le corps pendant les
débats s'étaient sentis traités patrice
nordmann j'étais parti pour acheter un
fromage et moi je bouffe forcément là
j'ai faim donc m'a fait acheter du more
more more je sais pas quoi elle m'a fait
acheter du du jeu c'est pouquoi rateront
manrakhan très bref différents fromages
[Musique]
t'as pas seuls à 6 ballons mais je peux
vous le dire un peu de sel qui est pétri
ce matin qu'à new york ce matin
oui y'a pas de scène n'a pas de salle de
long de 25 ans qui participe en ce
moment au programme les princes et
princesses de l'amour sur w9 un vrai
métier à côté il est policier
que voilà si sa prestation dans
l'émission fait sensation l'ambiance est
beaucoup moins légère du côté de sa
hiérarchie qui apprécie visiblement pas
beaucoup sa participation au programme
et ses publications sur les réseaux
sociaux déjà pas pour faire copain
copain c'est chaud qui pensaient que
c'est terminé pour la police mettra à
l'essai s'éteindre envie de vous faire
virer
j'ai envie de chercher autre chose
d'accord vous aurez à quoi tu as besoin
vous avez surtout envie de kent le
cerveau le plus primitive mais celui qui
nous domine au bout du compte c'est le
cerveau reptilien qui n'a que deux
objectifs safer servat moyens non alors
non sens l'objectif c'est de projeter
dans l'avenir mais gêne il faut qu'ils
aient dû des gènes de davie canada
santander 200 ans pour ça faut deux
choses 1 que je mange pour de nourrir 2
que je fasse l'amour pour arriver à me
pas me reproduire et donc lui a que ça
qui compte
elle est où la baballe à laval la balle
c'est le bon julian ça il va chercher la
baballe qui va chercher la baballe ses
yeux
oui iran la baballe julian qui rend la
balle fouet
c'est quoi c'est peut-être camélia pas
les chiens pourquoi mais j'aime pas les
charges les trouve moches
ils sont moches au puits un bouge pas
tes belles petites oreilles notre
marseillaise exagère toujours un poids
[Musique]